did you see a red truck this morning
in the canyon
it was parked in my driveway
probably hunters right
i don't know
i heard about you
just didn't know it was this canyon
did they threaten you at all
not overtly but
i have definitely been made to feel
threatened
where you from
originally new orleans
i teach at the university
out here things are a little different
most folks
handle this sort of thing amongst
themselves
i guess i'm not most folks
should we call for backup
what backup we've got two officers to
cover 300 square miles i don't feel safe
in my own house there isn't enough law
in this whole state to make you feel
safe behind you
afternoon gentlemen
everybody step forward you put your saws
down you take your masks off what
i wanted to ask you something
if i tell you to promise you won't say
anything
tell me what
these guys keep coming back why do you
think that is
why do you care so much
go back to sleep
[Music]
why don't you come inside
we can work it out what's the matter
hey where you going
i wonder sometimes how much you choose
to be the person you are
we're here
sometimes it feels like things never
change
but i promise you
they do
they have to
[Music]
you